[Music]
2154 from indonesia okay so i've been
playing d4 a lot more
in in the last couple speed runs just
showcasing positional ideas but i want
to switch back to e4
for this one okay so
let's play now in the french we've been
playing
the advanced pretty religious okay never
mind he plays b6 so he plays b6 which is
which is a transposition to owen's
defense
generally this is reached via e4 b6 d4
e6
and white has a bunch of setups that i
am aware of which give white an
advantage my favorite one is to play
knight c3
and then bishop d3 basically to over
protect the e4 pawn if you know anything
about the system for black you will know
that this there's this idea of going f5
and by over protecting the pawn with
your minor pieces you are taking the
sting out of that bishop e7 is not very
good there should be seven as far as i
know is quite passive and now we just
develop normally like i don't see a
reason to reinvent the wheel here i
think the best bet is to go either
knight g2 or knight f3 either developing
move is good i think i think we're gonna
go for a standard development with
knight f3 let's just go standard
development
yeah now
there's an interesting subtlety in these
positions okay black wants to play d5
right
and let's imagine the black plays d5 so
if black plays d5 and then we play e5
black can put the knight on e4 so one
move i like to make in these positions
is queen e2 so that if black plays d5
and we play e5 knight e4 now loses a
pawn black is forced to retreat to d7
but our opponent is not interested in
playing it
in any principled way he's playing sort
of a hippo setup which is
actually quite viable there's nothing
terribly wrong with this white's better
but
it's not
it's not winning or anything like that
castle's probably hill castle
knight bd7 okay so here we can basically
choose between playing positionally and
tactically
if we were to play positionally there is
a sort of a standard idea that is often
recommended in such positions
to weaken black's light squares does
anybody know what it is
and for that reason in the hippo you'll
often see black playing the move a6
before developing the knight to d7
and that is the move
no not a4 because a4 can be just met
with a6
a4 can be met with a6
yeah bishop a6 is what i'm talking about
and traditionally it's considered that
such a move in many different openings
tends to
so let's try it let's see what happens
if we trade the light squared bishops
i'm not personally enthralled with this
concept because i feel like our bishop
on d3 is aiming at the king side so in
the event that white the black castles
it is nice to get to to retain our light
squared bishop but at the same time
uh this does create as you can see this
this creates a complex of weak squares
on the queen side which we can try to
exploit through subtle positional play
castles okay
i want everybody to notice that i'm i'm
not rushing the development of my last
piece
right i don't have anywhere particularly
sexy to put this bishop right now so i'm
just going to keep it on c1 for the time
being i'm going to keep it on c1 and
i'm gonna try to
when the position clarifies
then
we will hopefully find a worthwhile
square for the bishop so
many good moves in a position like this
if we want to continue with our campaign
of queen side pressure though we should
definitely play the move a4 very typical
motif you're basically just trying to
shove this pawn down at a5 and and
create pawn pressure on black's position
he plays c5 a c5
is an interesting move
we can respond to this with d5
we can also ignore and play a5
although the issue potentially with a5
is that black and play c takes d4
although there we just play knight takes
d4 i don't see a problem that's almost a
sicilian
that that'll almost lead to a sicilian
structure
where black has a bunch of these light
square weaknesses on the queen side i'm
fine with the sicilian structure
but but if i were playing a classical
game i'd probably play d5
and get a benoni benoni type of
structure
but but here i want the position to be
open
i don't mind that hopefully everybody
can understand how
why it is that by bringing our pawn up
like this we are when i say the words
like causing pressure or putting
pressure
uh hopefully you understand what that
means i'll explain that a little bit
more after the game to those people who
are
you know because that concept of
pressure in chess can be very confusing
admittedly and uh you know
okay so so now i think in the name of
putting more pressure yeah i love the
move rook d1 because this brings a rook
into the game we know this is a good
square because it x-rays the queen and
it also supports the center so
this is the best way to put pressure you
make moves that increase the tension and
the position but we know for a fact that
this is improved this is an improving
move
notice how i'm not changing the
structure in the center it's a it's a
standoff
we're basically staring at each other in
the center that who flinches first
now we might still play d5 okay 98 is a
bad move
the first thing i notice when 98 is
played is that it
it cuts the connection between the rooks
what does that mean what move
is now a lot more appealing
now that black has played knight e8
what move immediately comes to mind well
that's this is what why pressure is so
good right we were holding that pawn on
a5 for a while
waiting for the best opportunity to win
the rook
very good 14 move game
that is
disappointing
but it is a direct product of the
pressure that we were putting on black's
position
it's a direct product of the pressure
that we were putting on black's position
yeah not a very good opening by our
opponent
but there's still a lot to talk about
here so
yeah we'll we'll get to that
yeah so so these openings are
i just never recommend them to anybody
because they're bad and you
you know you might see hikaru play these
types of openings but that's because he
is incredibly good at weaseling his way
out of
bad positions
and um
at 2100 you certainly should not play
there are much better offbeat openings
that actually give you a chance to get
an interesting position i mean at the
very least if you're playing e6 play the
french you know the french is a great
uh kind of second rate opening that that
gives you a combative game
and if you want to play something super
offbeat there's plenty of stuff that's
like just a lot more interesting than
just giving up the center like this
because no matter how white sets up
their pieces black is going to be worse
which is why i don't really see the
appeal of this
opening okay so we played knight c3 and
bishop d3 which is
i think one of the main lines so here
the main move is knight f6 bishop e7 is
very passive
in this opening the bishop usually goes
to b4
but the move bishop before here
let's see who paid
especially careful attention to the
earlier games in the speed run i have
recommended a move here that we have
played
several times in the speed run
and that's knight e2
92
by the way common mistake in notation is
to say knight g to you don't have to say
knight g2 because there's only one
knight that can go to e2 the other one
is pinned
and the purpose of knighted to it knight
g2 is to connect the
i just made that mistake knight e2 is to
connect the knights
and if black plays for instance knight
f6
then we can just castle
and if you compare this position and
this position
well compare the placement of the knight
on e2 versus f3 what move does black
have here
it is totally harmless here well it's
obviously bishop take c3 that's the
whole point of connecting your knights
like this you take the sting out of the
potential
for a trade
whereas with the knight on f3 black
actually just wins upon this is a common
blunder
very common blunder
by the way another very common mistake
listen carefully because this is a
mistake tons of people make
is you get a position like this
and then you say hmm well i see that my
opponent is threatening to win the pawn
so let me pin the knight
in order to defend the pawn indirectly
while also developing a piece
on the face of it this logic sounds good
but there's a a concrete flaw with this
move in particular and with the concept
of using a pin to defend upon what is
what is the flaw what is black's best
move here
i see this all the time
no not castles oh if black castles then
white already has like e5 and stuff then
it's justified
yeah so black plays h6 you might say
well no big deal i just play bishop h4
but here black plays g5
and we've lost a pawn because now you're
black has gotten rid of the pin and
black can take on e4 immediately even
because because you can't take with a
knight
so you're forced to take the knight but
now you have given up the bishop aaron
you have made two moves with the bishop
only to trade it for a knight that has
moved once and black is doing great here
so just an important note if i were to
get myself into this position
who can propose a way of defending the
e4 pawn
who can propose the best way of
defending e4 pawn also one of the only
ways
sunny diet deity if you play h6a3 black
will take the knight with check
and you lose a piece on g5
yeah queen e2
but the whole reason that we put a
knight on e2 rather than an f3 here
block plays d5
and here you get into this very annoying
situation where black starts putting
pressure on your knight etc etc so
for that reason i proposed the setup
with knight e2
so that after knight f6 you can simply
castle you can also play a3 and kick the
bishop away and bishop takes c3 is
totally harmless due to knight takes c3
why not f3 to prevent the shenanigans
asks nikhil
97 when when are you proposing that we
play f3 here
well as you know f3 is a very weakening
move you can play f3 there's nothing
terribly wrong with this move but i
don't like the weaknesses that you're
creating on the queen on the king side
and these are permanent
so f3
f3 is very weakening
very weakening
um
also black can try to run you off the
board with his pawns d5 e5 c5 and as you
can tell you're you're starting to oh
and i think when h4 queen takes d4 is a
problem
in certain positions so f3 in french
structures is not usually a good move
okay bishop b7 so notice how we're
flexible right
you might look at the say well didn't
you just say
that
you're proposing that you developed the
knight t2 yeah but the situation has
changed black's bishop is now not on b4
it's on e7
and that changes our method of
development
a very important skill in the opening is
to like not get that's why system
players struggle by the way another
reason why i don't recommend starting
with the london because you don't
learn how to adapt in the opening you
play the same moves over and over again
okay knight f3 knight f6 now we play
queen e2
once again the purpose of queen e2 is
that if we castle instead black has d5
and black can put the knight on e4 not a
big deal but something that we can
easily prevent with queen e2
okay d6 is
passive but okay black setup is fine
this is
i would say probably 0.5 or 0.6
according to the engine
okay so bishop a6 super common idea in a
million different openings if you are a
london player
then get out of the stream
if you are a london player or a tory
player you should recognize that concept
so if you play
a london against the king's indian
the
london in the london against the king's
indian this idea exists
so something like this
yeah
oh actually man no so the the line that
min likes to play he puts the bishop on
c4 in the london
and a lot of our games go like this like
bishop b7 queen e2
and in bullet i'll often forget to go a6
i'll go like
some random move and then he'll play
bishop a6
very similar idea right white is
weakening all these light squares after
queen c7 if you're paying attention to
my speedrun game what should white do
here
what is the automatic move for white in
this in these types of positions the
automatic idea
yeah it's to play a4a5
and and create very similar pressure to
the the kind of pressure that we put in
our opponent so you can see how openings
are connected like the ideas can be
borrowed from one opening to another
i can show you a million examples of
this idea
of course you're probably more familiar
with this idea on the king's side but
it's the same idea
it's just that when it happens on the
king side in an opening like the perk
like when you when you do this
you know you can immediately understand
the benefits of trading
uh the fiance because there's a king
here when there's no king it can be
harder to see it but it's the same type
of concept you're awakening the dark
squares here with the light squares
there etc
so back to the game queen e2 d6 castles
knight bd7 bishop a6 okay so he took it
castles and a4
so c5 i think is another mistake
c5 weakens black's position even further
creates a weak pawn on d6
it weakens the b6 pawn and it makes the
move a5 even stronger
no i i wouldn't say that taking a the
bishop was a big mistake i think black
is okay here if he's careful
so what should black do here well what i
would do with black is probably try to
smoke the queen out of a6 i would play
the move queen to c8
i'd play the move queen to c8
we would
presumably not trade we would probably
quit queen d3 queen e2
and now i would play the very typical
move a6
right this is a classic pawn arrangement
the idea is to meet a5 with b5
the idea is to meet a5 with b5 and the
game continues the white is better we've
got the center we would probably go
bishop g5 but
in such positions black is obvious
obviously black is solid
black is solid i mean this is this the
game is going to last a while rookie yay
unpleasant black is super cramped but
it is what it is
of us no
no at that point it was bad for black
no no it's not drowsh it's a it's just a
middle game you know what else i'd
consider
what i'd probably play in a classical
game with black is the move d5
so what i would say is okay um the
moment the queen leaves e2 the e4 square
we lose some of our control over the e4
square so d5 becomes a possibility and
then
e594 although here
no here probably white can just take and
go knight d2 and the pawn on e4 is going
to be lost
no this is bad this is bad i apologize
this is not the way
maybe d5 and 98 but this looks really
passive now we go a5 and
the situation becomes even more
unpleasant for black
although even here black is actually
very solid it white is not winning in a
position like the white's just better
but this is not losing black is still
solid even though he's incredibly
cramped after something like c6 but
these positions you don't win fast
okay but instead c5 a5
the line that i had to calculate cd
knight d4 knight c5 looks very dim we
just drop our queen back to e2
and look at how weak the c6 square is
right we're already threatening knight
c6
we're threatening it takes like there's
just a lot of pressure on black's
position
so instead he plays h6 weird move we
improve our position look d1
98 and the game ends very quickly so
if he had played knight takes b6 then
our placement of our rook on d1 is
justified we just play d takes c5 and we
win
we win everything
um so the way black should have played
is queen takes music only move
and here we would have a choice uh we
can definitely trade queens and get into
a much better end game where we have a
vastly superior pawn structure better
placed pieces
so uh d reasonable option
reasonable option number two is to not
if you
i wouldn't not trade queens i would try
to trade on my own terms
so you could say okay we're not afraid
of black taking our queen because our
rook on a6 is going to be sexy
so you can make a move like knight b5
and if black takes then black is in huge
trouble on the queen i mean a7 is
probably going to be lost and if black
loses a7 then black's queen side is
totally decimated
so i would play probably the move knight
b5
a good introduction to positional
pressure this game
kind of sad that black collapsed as
quickly as as he as he or she did
so any questions
knight ba forces the trade
one second we have a question from anita
no knight b8 blunders a rook
yeah
all right
[Music]